this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Kiwi co-creates super
cool hands-on projects for kids of all
ages that makes learning about science
technology engineering art and math fun
inspired creative confidence this year
with Kiwi Co Cuba Co is offering science
magazine podcast listeners the chance to
try them for free to redeem this offer
and learn more visit kiwi koat.com slash
magazine that's ke iwi co.com slash
magazine
welcome to the science podcast for March
8 2019 I'm Sara Crespi in this week's
show I talk with contributing
correspondent Lizzy Wade about new
evidence that the same black death that
devastated Europe in 14th century also
swung down and hit sub-saharan Africa
and Megan Cantwell talks with Gustavo
who Latisse about evidence for humans
hunting and butchering giant ground
sloths more than 12,000 years ago in
Argentina now we have contributing
correspondent Lizzy Wade to talk to us
about a completely different story than
we discussed last week this time we're
gonna talk about the extent of the
medieval plague most of us know about
the Black Death in Europe but turns out
the plague might have gone a lot further
than researchers had thought hi Lizzy hi
Sarah what has up until now been the
accepted extent of this plague during
the 14th century so most of us know
about the Black Death from these mass
graves in London and it really affected
all of Eurasia sending from at least
Russia over to the British Isles and
down to Egypt and North Africa and
around the Mediterranean world but once
it gets to Africa it encounters this big
environmental barrier which is the
Sahara Desert which is obviously a very
extreme and trying climate and since the
plague travels in fleas infesting rodent
populations historians had just sort of
assumed that it hadn't made it across
the Sahara Desert that it was too hard
thus the societies in sub-saharan Africa
had been spared this tragedy right there
was even some archeology or lack of
archaeology that back that up right
there was no written record of this
plague hitting sub-saharan Africa during
that time yeah there are very few
mentions of diseases there well there
are very few written records from
medieval sub-saharan Africa to begin
with although there are some some of
them have some kind of vague mentions of
epidemic diseases but that doesn't
really tell you what microbe is close to
nothing right and these plague pits
haven't been discovered the bay
advanced recently of course in the study
of the Black Death in Europe has been
into DNA and you can actually find the
DNA of the microorganism that causes
plague in the skeletal remains of people
who died from it and that hasn't been
found in Africa so far I was gonna say
what is the new evidence why are we
talking about whether or not the plague
made its way across the Sahara some
historians and archaeologists have just
been rethinking this a little bit
sub-saharan Africa in particular has
been envisioned as disconnected from the
rest of the world during this period
this medieval period European traders
weren't going there yet people just
thought it was off on its own doing its
own thing which is kind of a colonial
way of looking at things and people are
sort of reevaluating the story about how
Africa a sub-saharan Africa was
connected to the rest of the world and
finding lots of links through trade and
other other ways and so plague came up
as one of these possible ways because in
the 14th century this is the late 1300s
just as the plague is striking London
and all these are these medieval
European cities there's also this big
change and many sub-saharan African
societies a lot of sites are abandoned
and sort of never returned to some sites
are abandoned temporarily some sites
really shrink fast in size and in some
areas there's like some political
changes and other areas there's
environmental changes but this thing
seems to happen and a lot of societies
that cross a lot of those boundaries so
archaeologists started saying like what
is going on here could it be connected
to what's going on in Europe at exactly
the same time what were some of these
locations that were abandoned how
desperate are we talking here
so most of the archaeology so far and
this is a new idea so it hasn't been it
will continue to be explored are in
Ghana and in Nigeria there are sites
that are abandoned there's a sighting by
an app called a crow crow uh I'm not
quite sure if I'm saying that right it's
called an earthwork site this farming
settlement surrounded by a big ditch and
kind of thanks to mark the settlement
boundaries that one and dozens of other
earthworks settlements that have been
identified
in southern gone at that time they
thrived for hundreds of years before
being really suddenly abandoned in the
late 1300s there's a site quite well
known site in Nigeria called FA that
sort of considered to be the historical
homeland of the Yoruba ethnic group so
like really important for Nigerian
history and there's some evidence there
that there was a rapid abandonment in
the 14th century and then people
eventually came back unlike to Accra and
there's a site in Burkina Faso called
Curie Congo that wasn't actually fully
abandoned but after growing for a
thousand years and like doing really
well and having like all sorts of
interesting things happened to it it
just shrinks suddenly and half it is cut
in half in the span of decades or maybe
even years and a lot of these places you
don't see a coming there's no evidence
that of invasion or increased conflict
they seem to be doing just fine living
the way that they always had and then
suddenly something changes for the much
worse and you mentioned in your story
that this pattern in the archaeological
record matches what happened during the
Justinian plague yeah so plague is one
of the few diseases that kills enough
people fast enough to really leave a
mark in the archaeological record even
something like Ebola today would not
spread this fast or kill this many
people in the past or something like
that could emerge and the reason that
the Justinian plague is a particularly
good comparison for archaeologists I
think is because at this point in the
British Isles you also have a real
dearth of written records there's some
monks saying like my abbot died in this
pandemic or whatever or epidemic but
like they're not very specific not a lot
of people are writing unlike when the
Black Death had slaves
centuries later that's much more well
documented historically so you know with
this Justinian plague in the British
Isles you just have the archaeological
evidence to go on and it does look
pretty similar to what's happening in
Africa so you mentioned there was no
ancient DNA evidence but there is some
modern DNA evidence that the plague did
travel to Africa yeah precisely so there
is no ancient DNA plague DNA from
sub-saharan Africa and sub-saharan
Africa is not a great place for DNA
preservation people really have to look
very hard and have a lot of luck but
there is sort of a very evocative hint
in a strain of plague that's endemic
currently in Central and East Africa
mostly kind of in the highlands that
will like hang out in rodent populations
and then emerge periodically to kill
people this strain of plague is really
really old and it seems to be based on
ancient DNA evidence from Europe and
actually from Russia
it's descended from a strain that was
killing people in Russia during the 14th
century so like that shows that this
plague strain eventually made it to
Africa there's nothing quite sure when
this is probably not the strain that was
that was killing the people in West
Africa that we talked about that we just
talked about but it does seem to enter a
lot earlier than many many historians
and other people who think about disease
always thought is there any theory about
how it would have traveled during that
time period were there roots that that
have been suggested sure yeah there are
like tons of trade routes that connect
Eurasia and Africa and really the rest
of what people call the old world at
this time there's like a really thriving
Indian Ocean trade that's bringing goods
and people and presumably diseases all
between the Middle East India Southeast
Asia Africa East Africa there's very
extensive trans-saharan trade routes
these are like things that are quite
well known it's just like nobody had
thought that the plague could have
traveled this way well what about one
other line of evidence that you
mentioned I think it's in your story I
know that it was part of the search for
visuals to go with this piece he's a
Saints that are showing up in Ethiopia
that are associated with the plague in
Europe how did that happen does anyone
know nobody really knows yet the two
sort of key Saints here are called Saint
row and st. Sebastian their association
with plague is a little bit folkloric &
piecemeal but lots of European plague
victims and sufferers and people just
worried about it we're praying to these
Saints kind of during the 15th century
maybe a little earlier and at some point
Ethiopians start praying to them - why
the sudden interest at the same time
that this black death strain at the
right potentially arriving that these
Saints would also arrive like that
that's pretty evocative besides just
looking for that ancient DNA
that this is the bacteria we're looking
for in a skeleton from the exact time
that we want is there anything else that
researchers are going to be looking for
to try to tighten up this theory ancient
DNA would really be the Silver Bullet
that would clinch this case it would be
undeniable that plague was causing these
societal changes in medieval sub-saharan
Africa in the meantime what
archaeologists are trying to do is to
see how plague might have affected these
societies so like there's this 14th
century event whether that's play girls
something else that they don't know yet
clearly there's some kind of before and
after and what archaeologists are
starting to do even in the absence of
this conclusive DNA proof that it was
plague is starting to explore exactly
what the effect was on these societies
what did these societies look like after
this what appears to be quite a
traumatic event all right well thank you
so much Lizzy thank you Sarah
Lizzy wade is a contributing
correspondent for science you can find a
link to her story at science magda org
slash podcasts stay tuned for Megan
camels interview with Gustavo Pilates
about evidence for humans hunting and
butchering giant ground sloths
[Music]
this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Q eco creates supercool
hands-on projects for kids that makes
learning about steam fun with a Cuba Co
subscription each month the kid in your
life be it your own kid your neighbor's
kid a niece or nephew grandkids will
receive a fun engaging new project which
will help develop their creativity and
confidence the projects are designed to
spark tinkering and learning and kids of
all ages there are seven different types
of crates to choose from you've got
tadpole crate for infants koala crate
for naturally curious preschoolers all
the way up to the Eureka crate and
that's for me you and anyone else over
14 cubic O's mission is to empower kids
not just to make a project but to make a
difference everything is created by cue
eCos team of in-house product designers
and rigorously tested by kids which
means they can do it and they won't
break it before it's done every crate
includes the supplies needed for that
month project easy-to-follow
instructions and an educational magazine
to learn more about that crates themed
cubic Oh is offering a science magazine
podcast listeners the chance to try them
for free to redeem this offer and learn
more visit kiwi cocom slash magazine
that's ki wi co.com slash magazine
you
towards the end of the Pleistocene the
time span about 2.5 million years ago to
12,000 years ago
large animals known as megafauna started
disappearing by the masses some suspect
that the introduction of a new predator
humans contributed to this extinction
event but that the Pampas region of
Argentina might have provided a refuge
for these mega mammals
I'm here with Gustavo Polyjuice to talk
about new evidence of exactly when these
megafauna started disappearing in the
Pampas region hey Gustavo thanks for
joining me how you doing Megan thanks
for calling yeah of course to start out
with could you describe what some of
these giant megafauna looked like that
went extinct during the Pleistocene well
this megafauna was very common in the
pampas of Argentina and during the
Pleistocene I am talking for example
about a giant ground sloth which weighed
about four tons I'm talking about the
cliff stones right is China Manila which
weighed about two or three tones we have
also mastodons three four tones like
their contemporary elephants actually it
seems to us South America lost at least
between 40 to 50 genera of different
species and most of them very very big
animals yeah it's a staggering amount
that's lost why do researchers think
that humans played a role in this
extinction
well because some of this phoner like
the gem known as loss of the glyptodont
suffered climatic changes along millions
of years and they were able to survive
and to recreate new species right in
order to adapt to these new
environmental conditions during the
Pleistocene and depletion but at the
very end of the Pleistocene there were
other predator humans right it was a new
species in in the continent in America
so we do not know exactly how the humans
impact they deserve
maiya Mama's but we do know that they
had some influence that we are trying to
do right now is trying to understand to
have a better knowledge about until
which extents humans collaborate help in
the extinction of these mega mammals
besides humans what other factors could
have contributed to the extinction of
these megafauna
the other thing some researchers say
that some of parasites or some
disruption in the environment brought by
humans could also affect the megafauna
not just dive leader egg hunting of the
animals but also some kind of secondary
changes that humans produce in their
environment your research centered
specifically in the Pampas region
why did some people suspect that this
might have been a place of refuge for
these giant animals what about the area
is so special well some of these people
is myself right I suspected that before
so I'm the first one to be contradicted
with a new research so we thought that
because of the Pampas is a very
extensive grassland with very high
productivity a kind of paradise for this
mega herbivores it may be the case that
this environment would act as a refuge
for these mega mammals during the Late
Pleistocene Holocene also considering
that the hunting pressure from the
emissions people was probably not very
high so we imagined in the past and a
scenario where our people and
Pleistocene megafauna were coexisting in
the pampas for several millennium what
did you discover that's changing well we
risk of a decide called Kampala border
where we found clear evidence of the
hunting of like giant sloth we have
several knives associated with bones of
this giant sloth Megatherium we had
dated these bones and we we got dates
between 7 to 9
thousand before present but the content
of collagen you know that the organic
part of the bone which is the dateable
material was very low and the deposit
ethological deposit was below Anna
stratum with very high organic contents
so now with dr. Thomas Stafford and dr.
Emily Lindsay
they develop new and very sophisticated
methodology to pretreat the samples in
order to separate what is really
collagen from the bone and with his
other substance like cubic acid coming
from this in organic sediments a
bob-tailed a layer which would
contaminate some hmm so you're saying
the previous samples that you took were
contaminated and that the radiocarbon
dates weren't as accurate as they could
be which was giving you that other range
of it yes you catch the point Megan we
are saying that because of the low
content of collagen that this sample
helped do two Dietetic process very
common in the Pampas the previous audit
had one date probably dated Colette him
plus humid and full the acid and it that
happen in this side we suspect that the
same would happen in the other side
which produce early Holocene dates so
now your new dates are saying that these
megafauna did not persist in the
Holocene sand they since they didn't
make it to 12,000 years before now
exactly we are saying that given the
fact that we have this accurate and
proceed for the Calvin date we suspect
about the other early Holocene dates in
a pampas and it had happened then the
time of coexistence between humans and
megafauna reduced a lot reduced to one
to two thousand years instead of five to
six thousand years right the time span
gets shorter and that case is increased
the possibility that humans are
had some impact some influence in the
extensions of these places info now is
there a chance that there any other
Pleistocene megafauna that could have
persisted into the Holocene or do you
not see any evidence of that given this
new way of dating I think that there is
one animal deck which is called the
tattoos see Guinea which is a big
armadillo but not very big but is bigger
than a current contemporary armadillo
and this animal which weighed about 50
60 or 70 kilos it's the chance that this
armadillo survived but in regards to the
big animals like giant sloths or
gliptins the really big ones yeah the
real big ones the one who weighed more
than one ton where booga very we were
suspicious about that possibility but
again Megan I have to say that we have
to read eight all the other sites now
right with this with this new
methodology because we are suspecting
that these samples were contaminated but
we cannot be completely sure until we
perform a series a new radiocarbon dates
following the same a tautology
so with this armadillo was it not hunted
by people is that a reason that it could
have persists no it was handed by people
but because of their smaller size it has
a more high rep relativity rates so
maybe it was hunted but because of a
high reproductive rate compared with the
gliptins for example it seemed that it
was probably able to survive and also
mainly was more flexible to the climatic
change the next step with your research
is reading some of these samples that
you took from study sites in the past is
there also other areas that you want to
look into yes I mean we we are trying to
recreate some of their sites it seems
that the Pampas is one of the best
places to test these hypotheses because
we have an extended grass on boot
preservation and a huge variety
of displaces a mega mammals much more
for example than in Patagonia where you
have very good preservation of bone in
the caves right but the variety of mega
mammals at the end of the Pleistocene
was less let me tell you Megan I'm very
suspicious about all their sites in
South America right I think that between
the 1415 thousand years before present
there is not solid evidence of human
presence in South America at least thank
you so much you're very welcome Megan
Gustavo Politis is a professor of
archeology at the Universidad Nacional
del centro and university la plata in
WeDo situs argentina you can find a link
to his research at science magog slash
podcasts and that concludes this edition
of the science podcast if you have any
comments or suggestions for the show
write to us at science podcast at AAAS
though RG you can subscribe to the
podcast on iTunes stitcher whoever you
get your podcasts Spotify even or you
can listen to us on the science site
that's science magnet org slash podcasts
to publish an ad on the science podcast
contact mid-roll comm the show is
produced by myself
Sarah Crespi and Megan Cantwell and
edited by prodigy Jeffrey cook composing
music on behalf of science and his
publisher Triple S thanks for joining us